you know I used to play a lot of snakes
and ladders uh with my sister as a kid
and I assume this game was somehow an
English game or um and I was really
surprised when I visited India to
discover actually its Heritage is from
India this is actually a Snakes and
Ladder board that I found in the Pitts
River Museum in Oxford I mean it's a
beautiful board with these Snakes and
Ladders on it's a 72 square board and
square number 68 is the one you're
heading for and this represents vaa or a
Moka so you're you're aiming to actually
reach uh you know that's what uh the
Hindu religion is about rebirth and your
karma and what gets you to um a state of
mshar so interestingly The Snakes and
Ladders represents uh good things that
you do in life to reach MOA you know
helping other people or a snake uh will
be labeled with drunkenness and so you
will slide down the snake and and and
move further away from from your
destination and in this Hindu version of
the game you go round and round because
of course you're reborn so it's not like
snakes and the laders I played with my
sister we'd sit there waiting to try and
get the score which would get you to the
final Square interestingly this one you
go round on round reborn and see whether
you can do better this time in life but
I was quite interested in you know how
long does it take to to reach MOA you
know Nana how many throws of the dice am
I going to have to do in order to to get
to this Final Destination and that's
something actually turns out mathematics
is really helpful to to calculate it
involves a really beautiful little bit
of mathematics uh uh involving a matrix
which gives you the information about
how you're moving around the board
actually a good game is one where the
rules are so simple you get it within a
few seconds I think that makes good
mathematics as well Simple Rules give
rise to complexity so the rules are you
get to throw a dice it will be 1 to six
and you can move one two or three around
the board according to the throw of the
dice if you hit the bottom of a ladder
you shoot up the board if you hit the
head of a snake you slide back down
again so you're basically moving around
the board the weird thing is actually
when I was playing with my sister I used
to think I was somehow in control of
this you know that I was making her go
down snakes and that I was I'd somehow
done a great move to hit that ladder and
of course uh as an adult I realized
it's a weird kind of game because you're
just a machine a cog in this and it's a
weirdly actually unsatisfying game
because there's no agency by the player
and a good game should actually you
should be able to express yourself
through your moves and so um but that
said there's a really beautiful piece of
mathematics which um helps you
understand the Dynamics of this game
involves something called a marof chain
one of the key things is how I got to a
square does not affect which Square I'm
going to go to next cuz the only thing
you know if I'm on Square 72 it's just
the throw of the dice which is going to
determine where I go next doesn't matter
how many moves it took me to get to 72
so this is the important thing about a
markof process that it should not depend
on how you got there but just where you
are now is what's going to help you
determine where you're going to go next
Snak lad is a certainly example of that
so I thought I would explain this with
just a very simple Snakes and Ladders
board which I've prepared earlier so so
here AB board is actually just 1 2 3 4 5
6 up to the destination 9 okay but I
could put zero cuz that's where we start
so I'm going to put on a ladder so for
example if you get to square 4 you get
to shoot up to square seven however if
you're on Square eight you'll slide back
down to square two so this means that
there's a little bit of dynamism in the
way the game will play so the question
is if I'm throwing a dice how many
throws of the dice are expected before I
reach the Final Destination mock show
which in this case is is square number
nine well there's this important thing
which is uh the U transition Matrix
which is the key to understanding this
game so we're going to do a matrix and
we're going to have a row and a column
for each of the squares Of The Snakes
and Ladder board um so we're going to
start on the zeroth Square so we've got
a row corresponding to where we start
but then you can go to square one 2 3
actually Four is not somewhere where you
actually end up because you'll shoot up
to seven so we're going to miss four out
because you'll never actually sitting on
four so actually the next one is five
six seven and then eight you're never on
eight because you get sent down by the
snake back down to two so these are
actually the only positions that you'll
be on except for the final one where
you're right but we're not interested in
that because the game is won by that
point so these are kind of the
transitionary states of the ball can I
ask a silly question I seem to remember
when I played Snakes and Ladders as a
boy you had to land exactly on the final
Square you couldn't overshoot it so this
is important so you have to throw the
exact number if I'm on Square seven I
have to throw a two and if I throw a
three I stay on Square 7even this is
different from the Indian version where
actually you would overshoot and be
reborn so uh The Matrix will be
different um in that case if actually
you're allowed to restart the game but
in the classic kind of English version
um you have to get the exact score so
that will be important the point is that
this Matrix has a row for each of the
places where your counter is at the
moment and then what we're going to put
in this Matrix is the probability that
you move to another Square so actually
we have again columns for each of these
states so uh 1 2 3 but not four remember
cuz that you go up to s 7 5 6 7 so it's
a square Matrix a 7x7 Matrix and then
what you do with this Matrix is putting
if I'm on Square zero what is the
probability that with the throw of the
dice I'm going to be on square one well
I have to move off this so Square zero
I'm not going to stay on Square zero so
zero probability there but from here
it's one6 that I throw one one six
chance that I throw two one six of a
chance I throw three interestingly the
four one six of chance I throw a four
but that will end me up on Square seven
one six of chance I'll throw a five and
one six of a chance I'll throw six so so
that's quite sort of clear you know
there's like six possibilities and they
will end you up on different squares but
now what if we're on square one well you
can't go to square zero actually you
have to move somewhere off square one so
you will not on square one so that's a
zero chance there but the interesting
thing is here I can get to Square seven
with a throw of a six but I can also get
to square 7even with a throw of a three
because that gets me to the four square
where I go up a ladder so there's a two
in six chance that I will actually get
to seven and or I think all the other
cases are one over six from here
throwing of the dice and landing on that
square but because there is two ways to
get to Seven I get 2 over six so now
we'll go to row two we do again the
probability from row two on Square two
that you're going to get get to each of
these different squares but something
interesting happens here because
actually I can remain on Square two
because I throw a six get to square
eight Square eight sends me down the
snake to two so there's a one in six
charms actually I'll stay on to square
seven there are two ways I can get there
I can throw five or I could go up my
ladder so what about Square three well
notice Square three I can also get to
square eight again so I can shoot back
down to square two so there'll be a 1
over six chance cuz three plus a roll of
five will get me down can I stay on
three no I don't I can't stay on three
here three actually noticed that I can
actually win so um which we're not
recording here so we're not going to see
the whole uh you know total six lots of
one over six because one of those is a
winner so three I can go to Five I can
go six and again I can throw one to get
um the ladder or I can actually just get
seven I throw a four but notice here we'
got 2 3 4 five it's the one over six
actually will give me a win but we don't
record that in the transition Matrix
okay what about on five well again I can
get down the snake by throwing and
getting on the eight here I've got zero
I can stay on five because now from five
I've got to get nine so if I throw a
five or a six I'm throwing too many so
then I will stay where I am so so now
it's interesting that you stay here two
out of the throws actually stick me
where I am throw of a one will get me
here and now I'm past the ladder so
actually there's only one way to get to
Seven from five again there's one
winning move so you'll see that 1 2 3 4
five but there there are two where I'm
actually just stuck and so the same will
happen with here I can again keep on
going down that snake from from six
going to eight here it's zero zero but I
actually can stay stuck here but now
there are three different throws which
are going to stick me there and then one
way to get and then what about from
Seven well again I could still go down
the snake get to two but now I could be
stuck with four different throws which
keep me on seven okay going get a two so
there's the transition Matrix and this
is going to help us to tell how many
moves it's expected to make to win this
game so how do we do that should we call
this Q so some more brown paper
[Music]
braid so this Matrix is actually
representing where you're likely to be
after one throw of the dice and a sixth
of the time you're going to be on the
squares 1 to seven um so what we want to
work out is um if if we play the game
keep on throwing the dice over and over
again how many times are we likely to be
on a particular Square starting from the
the zeroth square so this is after one
roll of the dice sixth of the time
you'll be on each of these squares the
lovely thing is if I Square this Matrix
that will then tell me what happens
after two throws of the dice because
that's what squaring The Matrix does and
so the the new probabilities in here
will be uh will tell me actually the
chances of being on each of these
squares after two throws of the dice and
so this is what's going to help us to to
calculate the number of expected turns
it's going to take before before we
reach the end because what I need to do
I I start with the identity Matrix a 7
by7 Matrix and then I take this is one
throw of the dice and the first row will
tell me kind of the odds of being on the
Square so there's one in a sixth chance
that after one throw I'll be on one of
the squares 1 to seven but the square of
this Matrix will tell me after two
throws of the dice how many times I'm
likely to be on the squares and three
throws of the dice now we want to know
how many throws of the dice are expected
to reach the end but it it could go on
infinitely um and so actually what we've
got to do is to
calculate um an infinite sum of matrices
and we're going to add up the first row
and the first row uh if we add up the
entries in the this infinite sum of
matricies that's going to tell us how
many uh times will'll be on each of
these squares if we play the game
infinitely before we reach the end so
we've actually got to calculate this
infinite sum which looks like oh my God
how am I going to do that with matrices
and things like that but look there's a
really cute bit of algebra which happens
because if I do I the identity Matrix
minus my transition mates q and look
what happens when I multiply a finite
bit of this sum well let's take 1 Q + Q
^2 up to Q to the N was a very nice
thing that happens here because the
identity Matrix just repeats this but
then I'm taking minus Q * this I get q
q^2 q cubed up to Q to the n + 1 so
actually this is equal to the identity
Matrix minus Q to the n + 1 because all
the other terms get canceled out I've
got this I but the Q gets canceled by
this minus Q * the I uh that's
interesting but what what happens I want
the infinite sum but the amazing thing
is n tends to Infinity this translation
Matrix gradually gets kind of with
smaller and smaller entries so the
interesting thing is Q to the n + 1
tends to the zero
Matrix so this means that this infinite
sum that I'm trying to calculate If I
multiply by it by I minus Q I get to the
identity Matrix so actually this means
that this infinite sum that I'm trying
to calculate
plus Q ^2 plus all the way up to
Infinity is actually equal to the
inverse Matrix of I minus
Q now this is something that you get
taught at a level maths or um first year
undergraduate how to invert a 7x7 Matrix
actually most computer algebra uh
packages will have such a function in it
so this means something really beautiful
I first I I needed to calculate
infinitely many matrices add up all of
the entries in the first row add of
those together and that's the expected
value now I just need to calculate this
inverse of a a matrix I minus the Q that
I've written down here and so actually
you inverting a 7x7 Matrix is not a
trivial thing uh so I actually got a
computer algebra package to do it and
what it told me is that the if I add up
the entries of the first row of this
Matrix it came to 10 so the expect
number of throws of the dice to win this
game is
10 and I I find that really beautiful
that this kind of bit of Matrix
mathematics with a little bit of this
algebra and a little bit of uh kind of
you know infinite algebraic expressions
can tell you how many times you need to
roll the dice to expect to win the game
I imagine the Matrix looks a lot more
complicated for like a 100 square Gap
well yeah so I actually did it for this
snakes and laders board here again there
are 72 squares but remember that you
have to remove the bottom of the ladders
and the tops of the snakes so that goes
down to a
52 um Square Matrix so it's a 52 by 52
so that's pretty big um so as you
calculated this and I had to use the
computer algebra package to do the
inversion of uh the identity Matrix
minus this actually you actually also
have to remove the Final Destination
which is the 68 Square um and it turned
out that uh you need
59 throws of the dice I think it was uh
in order to reach moire but there was a
very interesting thing that I
experimented with because you'd think
that by removing a snake I might
decrease the number of throws I need to
get to moxa because you know snakes seem
to be bad however when I removed one of
these snakes the expected number of
throws went
up now I was like why is that what what
what happened there what I'll tell you
why if I remove this snake it shoots up
to 77 now that's kind of what why why is
it actually harder to get to the end
even though you've removed something
which seems to be taking you further
away and the reason is that you're
getting a second go at this big ladder
which is really helping you to get
towards the end so this snake is
actually helping you perhaps the message
here it pays to pay behave badly because
it gives you a second chance to behave
well and reach mocka so there are some
surprising things you know you can
actually see and and this actually
happens a lot with mathematics can
sometimes help you that you think a a
new road will help uh the traffic but
sometimes it can actually cause the
traffic to get worse and so there are
unexpected things that this kind of
mathematics can reveal and in this case
it reveals that snakes sometimes help
you I remember uh I used to make my own
Snakes and Ladders boards at home you
know I designed my own I learned and I
once made one where every Square you
landed on was a snake or a ladder and
that only afterwards I realize you do
need a few blanks you know you want that
sweet spot between you how many ladders
and or snakes do I need actually to make
this game not go on forever or not
finish too quickly so um this kind of
mathematics really helps you to uh you
know n Advance well actually it's too
many throws of the dice I need let's
stick in another ladder and see what
that that does so so people can have fun
you know you should take your snakes and
laded border at home uh generate this
Matrix uh put it in a computer algebraic
package which there are online and and
see what the expected number are for
each of your different Snakes and
Ladders boards Professor you spoke at
the start of this video quite negatively
about snakes and ladders and we referred
to us almost just machines playing this
with no agency I have to ask the
question of you as a mathematician is
this a game that you have played with
the young people in your life do you
introduce young people to snakes and
ladds or do you avoid this because of
your your snobbish
attitude um I actually yeah I I think
this game is Dreadful so it doesn't give
you any agency and therefore you can't
express uh you know some strategy in
order to um play the game however you
might think therefore oh he must be a
lover of Chess and the Chinese game of
Go which are pure strategy um but no I
think those also have a problem and it's
comes down to actually playing with a
young person uh that if somebody knows
how to play a strategic game then the
the junior player has no chance to beat
them so you know Kasparov against Donald
Trump is not an interesting game when
it's uh chess they're equally matched if
they're playing snakes and ladders for
me The Sweet Spot is a game which has
some element of chance but still some
element of strategy in order to help uh
so you can express
some some part of your intellect in
playing the game so you know if you
going to push me I think one of the
really lovely games that is simple to
learn and I play with my kids is
backgamon because backgamon throughout
the dice is important so you know you
really can win even if you're a
first-time player on the other hand with
good strategy using the dice in order to
move your counters such you're not
exposed and they don't get captured
still strategy can help you even if you
get bad throws of the dice actually to
win that game so and it turns out it's
one of the most ancient games as well so
it's related to um a racing game that
you can find in the British museum which
is about 4,500 years old and is thought
to be the first board game ever it's
called the royal game of or it's a dice
game but the dice that they use are not
the cube shaped dice we use in Snakes
and Ladders but a little tetrahedron or
actually several tetrahedron so this is
kind of weird because that's a
triangular based pyramid and that
doesn't land with a face up with the
faces down and so what they did with
these dice is they colored two corners
of the four corners on the tetrahedron
and you would throw a lot of these
tetrahedron and you would count how many
colored Corners are pointing up and that
would be your Go in the royal game of or
and so that's regarded as one of the
very first board games and B gamman kind
of grew out of that game someone
watching this is probably thinking why
the heck does Marcus know so much about
games why is all this game stuff in your
head go on okay well uh I have just
written a new book which is called
Around the World in 80 games and this is
kind of uh this passion I've had for
collecting games wherever I'm traveling
on my mathematical journey I I thought
oh it' be lovely to put together kind of
the story of my my journey for the many
decades digging out games and so um and
when I listed them turned out to be 80
games or game themes and so I thought oh
that's perfect I'll use Jules Vern's
story of phyas fog going around the
world and actually philas fog loved
playing games he he loved um his game of
choice is a card game the game of Wist
which is one of the games in the book
and he actually would spend more time
looking at his cards than the views out
the window so they arrive in India in
the book and he's just um managed to win
Wist and take all of the tricks and he's
super excited by this and completely
misses the arrival in Bombay or Mumbai
all right people links below to buy the
book go and read this book there is a
snakes and ladders section of course
along with 79
others
okay so now I got these things so all I
have to do is convince you that that all
of the faces are the same that there
symmetries that take any to any others
so there you go like so you can see the
three-fold rotational symmetry here like
if I rotate it like that it's the same
and then the three on the back if I do
this they're also the same